ما الذي سيحدث في حالة عدم وجود صفقة خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي ،
لا أحد يعرف الخيارات كثيرة جدًا ،
وستكون الصعوبات كبيرة أولاً ،
حيث
لن يتم السماح للناس بالانتقال للعيش والعمل في
بلدان بعضهم البعض التي تنتمي لبريطانيا في
الاتحاد الأوروبي بحرية  ثانيًا ،
لن تكون قادرًا على القيام بالتجارة الحرة
بينهما ،
لأن بريطانيا لم تعد جزءًا من
السوق الموحدة ، لذلك ستكون هناك
طوابير طويلة طويلة من الجمارك والموانئ حيث
يجب فحص البضائع بحثًا عن قواعد
المنشأ للتعريفات الجمركية أوه  نعم التعريفات ستكون هناك
رسوم جمركية بين المملكة المتحدة والاتحاد الأوروبي ،
سيكون هناك تحول بمقدار 180 درجة عن
الوضع الحالي ، لكن الخبر السار
سيكون ، وهو أمر بسيط للغاية هو
أن الاتحاد الأوروبي في المملكة المتحدة سيضع
تدابير طارئة لذلك ستفعل الرحلات الجوية.  أن تكون
قادرًا على مواصلة اللوائح من شأنه أن يسمح
بأن بعض اللوائح المحدودة لن يتم
وضعها في مكانها بالنسبة للسلع الأساسية ،
ولا أحد يعلم ، أعدك إذا
كان هناك خروج بدون صفقة ، يوافق الجميع على أنه
سيكون فوضويًا في الملحق  eme
[موسيقى]